foreign
lives in a world of color
in powder
and paint
bright neons
branded Blues a black so black it tricks
the eye
[Music]
I love watching it go in
if Willy Wonka had a paint factory it
would be here in his artist studio and
paint lab on the south coast of England
eye candy everywhere you look
I would explain color as something that
can change our
emotions and our state and our way of
being as we interact with it and it is
our way really of
feeling the world inside us visually
Stewart's fascination with color was
sparked as a kid when his mom took him
to London to see Van Gogh's sunflowers
it's the first time I saw proper pure
pigment
but there's something in the painting
looking back that has this sort of joy
and it just kind of comes off the canvas
and my mum said I was in a state of
almost all like I was shaking in front
of this thing from there his lifelong
passion for pigment began Stewart's
artwork has been exhibited around the
world but his calling is something
bigger
so it's more than how do I make money
it's actually more how do I make art
accessible and give people
you know a chance to interact with it
he does so by developing and selling
affordable quality paints just one arm
of his non-profit art business
yeah so this is where we make all the
paints in the studio
oh it's something so satisfying about it
Stewart mixes Art and Science to make
the world that little bit brighter
there's some quite clever things that
are in this acrylic polymer that lets it
hold all this color
[Music]
but accessing color these days isn't
always as easy as Stuart would like and
I hate the idea that art or color or
materials are sort of gate kept in any
way shape or form because I really think
it's important that people have that
permission to kind of do their thing
with the stuff they need to do it
most recently Stewart noticed some
digital colors Out Of Reach now jailed
behind a paywall
a blue ocean away in Toronto graphic
designer Daryl Woods got the same pop-up
on his Adobe design software I can't do
my work without the Adobe products they
are just part of my everyday life I
think that pretty much goes for anybody
who works in visual communication
Daryl already pays eighty dollars a
month to use Adobe tools now creatives
like him face an extra fee just to
access some digital pallets if they
don't pay many colors they rely on fade
away the restricted pallets are from the
industry Kings of color Pantone
so this is a Pantone Swatch book so you
can see there's hundreds and hundreds of
colors if I create something on my
computer with a Pantone color and it
needs to be printed halfway across the
world that's a universal color no matter
where it's used that extra fee had
Stuart seeing red
and I instantly knew I could do
something about it and it took me about
two or three hours and then I'd created
this free tone plug sorry two or three
hours yeah
to get inside the software yeah and fix
this issue yeah I wanted to make it
better for everybody it was the patch
that people needed so I made it
Stewart's free tone palette is you
guessed it free he says around a hundred
thousand people have downloaded it
I was very surprised that Stewart was
able to do it and just how easy it is to
use it's it's it's no different than uh
when I used Pantone colors this was not
Stewart's first color Crusade oh you
wouldn't believe what Kapoor's gone and
done now in 2016 British Artist Anish
Kapoor secured exclusive artistic rights
to vanta Black then claimed to be the
darkest surface coating ever made
sparking a colorful battle
here it says uh up your sample so that's
not very nice is it so if it's a war you
want it's a war you're gonna get so in
typical fashion Stuart teamed up with
Scientists to make his own affordable
version the idea as always to make art
accessible to everyone are you the Robin
Hood of color
people say that it's a weird thing I
don't know but no one else is doing what
you're doing no I don't suppose to say
oh maybe it's just a weird geeky thing
that only I'm interested in which is why
no one's doing it
big business is interested in color too
the commodification of it from UPS Brown
to Home Depot Orange recent changes to
Canadian law mean companies can broadly
claim trademark over a color for a range
of services rather than in a specific
context like a product or logo it could
be a game changer says intellectual
property lawyer Sebastian Beck what
so historically you could claim uh like
a Tiffany blue box so you would say the
color blue as applied to the surfaces of
a box now you can more simply say in
theory you know I have applied to
protect the color blue in association
with jewelry
TD Bank is among the businesses applying
to trademark its color Pantone 361 in
case you're wondering but could another
bank use an almost identical green it
hasn't been tested in court yet even
experts are unsure how far this will go
something I color might be an instance
where you know you take a survey of the
public and see how close they think
these are
but even that is fraught you see color
is just so subjective
I have a slight card oh what yeah
actually color blind wait a second yeah
your color yeah and colorblind to blue
and purple which is a rare one
at least simple knows blue well enough
to make Tiff his cheeky version of
Tiffany blue it's one of the more
protected corporate colors that he's
determined to take back one brush stroke
at a time
we talk about Tiffany do they own blue
do they no who owns color no one can own
color color exists it's it's just a
phenomena of nature how can you own an
experience that your eyes have when they
see something